[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on la flotte chose à faire les chiffres
il ya une très grosse surprise que va
faire un max pokora tout à l'heure on va
parler de l'album bien sûr my way on
verra des extraits de l'émission passera
samedi soir sur tf1 mais pour le moment
bonjour luxe et des cafetières avec une
question on va rappeler aux
téléspectateurs
jean-luc y voit tout ce qui se passe
dans l'émission même pendant les pubs et
forcément ils nous balancent tout après
vous faites gars les gars voilà vous ai
tout dit pas question
c'est parti bonjour je m'appelle irène
je voulais savoir si vous aviez pris de
bonnes résolutions pour 2010 est et
surtout si vous comptiez dire moins de
conneries à part sa bonne année et bonne
année à vous je comprends votre
inquiétude il est nommé mais je vous
rassure nous continuerons à dire
beaucoup de bêtises dans l'émission
c'est dans notre adn et pmp va
s'améliorer mais les fondamentaux vont
rester des besoins toujours debout un
peu ning com cette entrée pleine de
modestie de cyril se situe le contexte
pour marquer le coup cyril avait décidé
de faire une entrée de football
américain en déchirant une bande rendre
à pied le projet était intéressant même
s'il allait voir d'épargné des choses
bizarres
déjà je sais pas pourquoi on a des pom
pom girls brésilienne pour du football
américaine mais enfin américain mais peu
importe ce qui comptait c'était le
déchirage de la banderole voici les
résultats
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bien
[Applaudissements]
à
en fait voilà qu'apple va aller à les
mettre un petit coup de ciseau ambassade
à rabat avait là et moi j'étais comme un
papa pas du tout peu n'aura pas du tout
en 2010 cette tp sera toujours beaucoup
de bonnes intentions mais surtout
beaucoup de ratage mais heureusement
dans ces cas là on peut toujours compter
sur le soutien des chroniqueurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment lui qui on a besoin de
rien on l'appelle à ingres avec toi il
est vraiment ingrat garaison bataille
c'est le pire toujours quand même de la
bienveillance dans l'émission grecque
même si certains chroniqueurs ont décidé
de changer de comportement par exemple
mathieu delormeau autant 2016 c'est une
pince haute et en 2017 il a décidé
d'être près de ses sous donc quand on
lui demande de rester un peu pour un peu
plus pour faire un lancement programme
voilà ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi qui comme les parkings vinci était
souvent en pleurs entamé val de travers
tout le procès c'est un bon camarade et
lui quand il est gentil
c'est vraiment un amour de mecs j'ai pas
envoyé de factures algérien n'a rien eu
le fait avec le sourire
il est content mais c'est sympa de vous
voir d'onde que d'autres avec ce visage
là vous avez compris à cette année
mathieu continuera à essayer de gratter
tout ce qui peut des cadeaux des places
de spectacle des pin's
d'ailleurs si vous allez dans les hôtels
et que vous ne l'utilisez pas tous les
échantillons fait mais un colis et c'est
un petit geste pour vous mais pour lui
ça veut dire beaucoup
mr la pince avait jeté son dévolu sur le
blouson de son dieu et m regardez cyril
hanouna sympathie
[Musique]
m
faire un gant la vie de remerciera de ça
si tu fais un cadeau la vie s'en
souviendra qu'à d'autres juste on croit
tous les journaux 12
[Applaudissements]
j'ai complété ma gueule ça tirait
c'était parce que vous dites mais je
suis toujours là avoir protesté
associations 1 sur l'auto après c'est
vrai des capucines voulez mais quand
même bien sûr ils l'aiment voila fr manu
repas lui et c'est pas du sant via cette
réputation que donner de la voix je vais
t'expliquer parce que ça continue après
à travers mes amis parce que quand il
veut quelque chose tapera thérèse à
mettre en travers de son chemin vous
avez vu pour capucine est ce que ça a
continué après il le voulait son blouson
un don qui la soutiennent grand numéro
de séduction une leçon pour tous
[Musique]
l'arctique est une région déjà
quand même un potager
[Musique]
reste une donnée non
jogging
parce que tu aux capucines et mathieu
sont très très très copains voilà se
connaissaient depuis des années donc
voilà c'est vrai qu'ils ont un rapport
un petit peu particulier dont je connais
un petit peu moins bien avec capucine
avec les mois mathieu je connais quand
même bien c'est vraiment pas la
casquette quand on a géré en civil ah
oui c'est vrai c'est auxerre qui est le
torse nu comme eminem et tout comme ça
dans un club
torse nu le même c'est vrai vous l'aviez
vu ma fille d'ailleurs tu es titre il
cartonne en booking mais c'est un trader
mais coûte
j'ai adoré la phase de mathieu auteuil
heurter titre cartonne au mardi
enfin car tous merci bon je vous passe
pas tout quand même et au final la
racaille a pas eu son blouson non comme
il a un coeur pour le consoler cyril lui
a proposé un petit rendez vous à fond
soit ce week-end bah je veux bien mais
si c'est comme pour les dîners comme
paula censé jamais vu je viens dire si
la capucine au bout de la [ __ ] mardi
c'est gentil toi maintenant mais bon là
les gens qui tapissent le tête-à-tête
dérange
ah ouais j'ai fait pour que tu est la
tête je termine en tête à queue
[Applaudissements]
mais lucide à domicile voilà je voulais
à témoin je voulais un témoin connaître
son attention ce que ça c'est ce que
s'est il dit pour faire le malin oui la
presse jean michel maire ça cache
quelque chose d'autre n'en à regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce pari
mathieu je vous adore c'est pour ça non
mais ça devrait quand même dommage que
ce bizarre que tout le monde debout
pense gay famille alors que tiber son
père alors le barça pense qu'avant mais
je vous dis ah ben ça se dit oui
j'aimerais bien mais non voilà j'aurais
dit qu'ils étaient joyeux saltimbanques
outre qu'il est gay jamais personne ne
sait où vous êtes vraiment encore sur
moi enfin publicis une famille vous avez
c'est parfois au delà après du physique
et des sentiments oui ça devient une
affaire personnelle en avait jusqu'à ce
jour je n'ai pas connu l'échec
ouais bah ouais ça commence maintenant à
n'ont pas dit mon dernier mot
ça devient gênant les mecs vous voulez
sean connery et carlo il est comme ça
tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
s'en sortir on n'y arrivera pas on y
arrive à mu et jean-michel un cahier une
lourdeur on peut compter sur lui
et si c'est une lourdeur affaire on peut
aussi compter sur lui la blague de la
semaine n est pas neuf 9 mai regardez
bien la tête de jean michel après ça
c'est un m cet homme était reporter de
guerre c'est pas possible
autre grande nouveauté 2010 est cyril a
voulu la présence chaque soir d'un
spécialiste médias oui ce qui est comme
un bel aveu sur ce que sont les gens
autour des tables aux micros mais s'il a
raison il faut ramener un peu
d'analystes dans le programme mais le
problème c'est qu'on est tellement plus
habitués que quand quelqu'un fait des
phrases longues et sérieuse les autres
chroniqueurs l'on regarde comme si
c'était un alien qui vont réagir encore
maxime est clairement on peut informer
dire les choses sans forcément explicite
et ou totalement ce genre de choses mais
est ce qui est important également c'est
hyper inconscient c'est inconscient et
c'est un peu malsain je pense que pour
retrouver la demi mesure et surtout le
juste équilibre et je bois vos paroles
[Applaudissements]
les taux d intérêts sous noirs
comment te sens tu restes dans le
denguélé nous appellerons giga gens
viennent quand on sait qu'à l'aller à la
presse karine on se dit ça peut tomber
sans n'importe qui il va poser une
question ça va me tomber sur le coin de
la gueule ça m haies l'été sauf un joli
conte à toutes choses qui arrivent mais
bien sûr avec bonjour lui qu'on a
d'autres choses sur les quatre tiers oui
alors je ferai des nouveautés de 2010
est donc avec le spécialiste médias n'y
a pas que ça y est une autre nouveauté
c'est beaucoup de jeu et surtout
beaucoup de magnifiques cadeaux à gagner
on l'a vu tout à l'heure avec les
vitrines des marques tous les jours par
les téléspectateurs mais aussi pour les
chroniqueurs
le problème c'est que matthieu delormeau
dans très très heureux en amour
parce que niveau je sais qu'à chaque
fois il face à ça à sa victoire il se
prend le mur mais comme il est
professionnel on voit pas du tout sur
son visage la jalousie et la frustration
enfin supra au début
et
[Applaudissements]
mais
valérie bénaïm ou une chronique
quotidienne ont gagné une chronique
quotidienne dans la campagne
[Applaudissements]
thierry moreau a gagné une augmentation
de son nom
[Applaudissements]
non
eh bien
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant j'ai quelque chose à
annoncer à capucine à naves capucines à
l'avs elle peut rentrer
capucine à naves aura son prime sur ces
8 en février où elle présentera un prime
time
ici même sur ce plateau ça sera la chef
devra tous les chroniqueurs et que ce
sera cap si nadal qui va présenter seul
l'egypte a dit avoir gelé ou d'entraidé
m'a dit augmenté au regard des mâles
[Applaudissements]
régis les salaires
montérégie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
brand classe grand talent mais oui c'est
pas grave vous êtes naturel non mais
vous vous reconnaissez sur ces images
malheureusement non melker le dernière
image elle est bizarre parce que c'est
bien on doit le revoir quand tu vas non
mais on revient on voit l'image on voit
pas ce qu'est en face si on va bien voir
et et au montage ça c'est parce que
c'est pas moi sa maman gens là vous
connaissez les images de synthèse issu d
une famille a été animée mais nous tous
hurlé tu es content pour capucine
déjà parce qu'elle avait eu un début de
semaine un peu difficile s'est fait
gronder par cyril
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai vérifié à l'eva 9 pour les
pigeonneaux un minitel c'est ça donc si
a priori un smartphone ne passe pas en
plus si elle se sert de son fondement
comme housse de portable ça c'est
dommage
la capucine est très actif sur les
réseaux sociaux et notamment sur
snapshot walryck notre public en toute
décontraction regarde
j'étais jeune femme qui vient très
souvent nous voir en public au labrador
elle danse à chaque fois qu'il vient de
publier
elle ne fait que dans ce même à la radio
annonce et oui c'est vrai c'est pas
gentil ça hein
ce qu'il faut pas faire non plus
capucine c'est caen reçoit un chanteur
on reste calme en fin d'émission
ou sinon toujours les bras collés au
corps un vianney il n'était pas là mais
les auréoles un petit
[Applaudissements]
là bas rien mais ça et ça casse un peu
le personnage allait comptant quelque
chose qui vous arrive rsa non c'est vrai
show de fans je ne perds jamais c'est
vrai puisque le point d'aller chercher
nos vêtements
oui vous souvenez oui oui et si vous
êtes c'était parce été sec ça sentait
bon la santé est incroyable les
acquéreurs
alors c'était un support à un happening
ici ok bon on l'a fait en week-end aussi
ah non ça devient gênant les maigres et
maintenant le scoop de la semaine le
sociaux c'est énorme pour la première de
janvier syrienne avait fait venir claude
alexis ah oui le voyant qui a une
particularité il lit dans les cochons
enfin je crois parce que regardez bien
il va bloquer sur les porcelets et avoir
un flash concernant quelqu'un de
l'équipe pour 2017
ça n'a pas été diffusée à l'antenne mais
depuis le temps qu'on s'intéresse à
cette histoire
on méritait de savoir vous invite à
passer comme ça déjà
jean wauthier pour tout le public tout
soit
j'ai justement parce que j'avais perdu
ma famille mon karma et temarii
moi j'aime ma région je m'arrête
je vois pas du tout un mariage c'est que
je ne vois pas du tout amoureux amoureux
imamura vous demande en mariage patoche
pas du tout ah ouais non pas tout bas
mais c'est attention un homme et je vous
assure il voit se chauffer je le connais
de vous donner dans la maison de
campagne il est imprévisible
non moi c'était pour faire plaisir
maintenant c'est le moment de passer à
tous qu'on n'aurait pas voulu voir ou
entendre cette semaine et on commence
par deux séquences étonnantes
tout d'abord la meilleure intervention
de la semaine d'isabelle morini-bosc ray
puis par le terrible secret de capucine
faut dire vous allez voir la peur
d'avoir les orifices qui sentent mauvais
ont discrètement pendant l'émission et
vérifie capucine là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme ça s'il ya des fulgurances
la semaine dernière on recevait patricia
kaas à kas casse des briques
regardez les individus des cas ils
peuvent pas tomber plus bas
enfin oui ça vous dit des bêtises que
des équipements rien
[Musique]
ça y est toujours
je connais des tas de moyens et puis
partir tu m'as piqué du nez mais ça fait
11 ans joue notre belle au bois dormant
à la mi temps
vous allez tous à paris
[Applaudissements]
c'est un film avec la super on l'a
entendu oui on a entendu les faits
étaient venus avec pas fini il est super
vous êtes bête non mais je vous le dis
ah bon c'est bien tout voilà allez allez
allez devoir vous amène à une fois bon
jean luc exceptionnel bravo jean luc
lemoine exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]